y llegó el momento de actualizar la
información económica en directo América
y por ello le doy la bienvenida
nuevamente a mi compañero Juan Pablo
lucumí acá estamos otra vez Andrés aquí
estamos Juan Pablo con la actualización
de las noticias económicas y vamos a
hablar sobre la guerra en Ucrania Así es
pues la Unión Europea ha propuesto
sanciones a empresas chinas acusadas de
vender equipos que podrían ser
utilizados en armas Para apoyar la
maquinaria de guerra de Rusia pues esto
según informó el financial Times el
domingo en este informe preliminar se
conoció que por lo menos siete empresas
chinas han sido incluidas en un nuevo
paquete de sanciones que serán
discutidos esta semana pues por los
estados miembros de la Unión Europea
todavía se conoce muy poco sobre el tipo
de estas sanciones sobre las cantidades
y también se ha hablado de otros
apartados para Irán y los drones de los
que se ha pues hablado en todo este
contexto de la guerra que ha
proporcionado Moscú y otra restricciones
de exportaciones a Rusia pero los
detalles y todo lo demás lo conoceremos
esta semana debemos esperar este nuevo
de paquetes
a que sea aprobado sobre este tema china
respondió con serias advertencias para
el bloque de los 27 países europeos
china se opone firmemente a las
sanciones ilegales contra china sobre la
base de la cooperación chino rusa en
cuanto a la cuestión de Ucrania china
siempre ha mantenido una posición
objetiva e Imparcial ha promovido
activamente la persuasión y ha
facilitado las conversaciones de paz si
los informes son ciertos las acciones de
la Unión Europea socavarán seriamente la
confianza mutua y la cooperación de
China y agravarán la división y la
confrontación en el mundo lo cual es muy
peligroso instamos a la Unión Europea a
que no tome el camino equivocado de lo
contrario china defenderá firmemente sus
derechos e intereses razonables y
legítimos
Juan Pablo vamos con las declaraciones
que hizo la secretaria del tesoro sobre
el límite de deuda en Estados Unidos
Andrés un tema que hemos estado viniendo
pues siguiendo desde enero que alcanzó
el límite de deuda Estados Unidos y que
se espera que el primero de junio como
lo ha dicho ella pues Estados Unidos
caiga en un impago el domingo la
secretaria del tesoro de ese país
Janette dijo en con el medio ABC news
que su prioridad era asegurarse que el
congreso hiciera su trabajo de aumentar
el techo de la deuda como se ha hecho
desde 1960 que se ha elevado una 78
veces ya un proyecto de ley que elevaría
el límite de deuda fue aprobado el mes
pasado en la cámara de representantes
pero su aprobación tuvo condiciones de
recortes de gasto que vaiden y su
bancada demócrata en el senado han dicho
que no aceptarán y que también han
asegurado que cuando llegue al senado lo
tumbarán yelén también advirtió que si
el congreso no se pone de acuerdo la
idea de invocar la décimo cuarta
enmienda para Elevar el techo de la
deuda podría Conducir a una crisis
constitucional estas fueron sus
advertencias
desde 1960 el techo de la deuda se ha
elevado 78 veces tres veces durante la
administración anterior siempre con
apoyo bipartidista y simplemente es
inaceptable que el congreso amenace con
una calamidad económica para los hogares
estadounidenses y el sistema financiero
como el costo de Elevar el techo de la
deuda es el trabajo del Congreso hacer
esto si no lo hacen Tendremos una
catástrofe económica y financiera que
será de nuestra propia creación y no hay
ninguna acción que el presidente biden y
el tesoro de los Estados Unidos puedan
tomar para evitar esa catástrofe Juan
Pablo es un tema que genera pulso todos
los años entre demócratas y republicanos
cuéntenos Cómo afectó esta noticia los
mercados esta jornada pues desde el
primer mercado ya se veía que estaba
afectando y la apertura de Wall Street
se dio en terreno mixto con el principal
indicador nasdaq reportando leves
pérdidas todos indecisos por el actual
panorama de incertidumbre frente a los
enfrentamientos como lo decía usted de
políticos entre demócratas y
republicanos sobre el techo de la deuda
y pendientes a la reunión que tendrá el
presidente Joe biden con los cuatro
principales líderes del Congreso esto el
día de mañana estaremos muy atentos y
aquí lo informaremos el mercado también
ya Pues empieza a hablar del dato de
inflación de Estados Unidos que se
conocerá el miércoles y todos atentos a
saber si disminuirá como lo ha venido
haciendo desde el máximo de 40 años o si
por el contrario aumentará y pues
también tendrá presiones sobre las tasas
de interés las bolsas europeas siguen
operando en su mayoría al alza teniendo
en cuenta el plan de sanciones que
planea la Unión Europea contra china que
hablamos hace unos minutos y movidos por
el dato de producción de Alemania que
fue sorpresivo y pues superó también las
predicciones Juan Pablo vamos a seguir
ahí en Estados Unidos hay declaraciones
importantes sobre la crisis bancaria
pero también sobre la Inteligencia
artificial Así es este fin de semana se
llevó a cabo la reunión anual de break
en Estados Unidos una reunión que
convoca a muchos inversionistas Y desde
ahí el multimillonario Warren buffett
dijo que los ejecutivos que llevaron el
sistema bancario al actual crisis
deberían enfrentar un castigo buffet
dijo abro
comillas si diriges un banco y lo
arruina arruinas sigue siendo un tipo
rico y el mundo sigue adelante Esa no es
una buena elección para enseñar a las
personas que tienen el comportamiento de
la economía en sus cierro comilla Yo
también advertencias acerca de que estas
personas deberían tener castigos como lo
hacen los políticos en todo el panorama
de lo que ha ocurrido en Estados Unidos
y haciendo referencia a los fracasos del
silicon y el signo tourbank que puso a
la primera Economía del mundo en una
crisis bancaria desde la crisis
financiera de 2008 sobre el tema de la
Inteligencia artificial dijo lo
siguiente abro comillas cuando algo
puede hacer todo tipo de cosas me
preocupo un poco porque sé que no
podremos
desinfectarlos cierro comillas y esta es
otra de las advertencias que ha hecho
pues para este escenario Ese temor
creciente de que la Inteligencia
artificial podría reemplazarnos a todos
Así es Juan Pablo Reino Unido es otro de
los países que se une económicamente a
proteger la amazonía como es eso y así
lo anunció el Primer Ministro británico
aportará 100 millones de dólares al
fondo amazonía una iniciativa
internacional liderada por Brasil creada
en 2008 durante la primera presidencia
del mandatario Luis Ignacio Lula da
Silva el fondo que actualmente
administra cerca de 740 millones de
dólares detuvo sus operaciones en 2019
cuando Alemania y Noruega que son sus
principales colaboradores Pues en
respuesta a los políticos y a las
políticas ambientales del expresidente
derecha decidieron dar un paso al
costado el fondo reanudó sus operaciones
desde el momento que Lula regresó al
poder en enero y se ha convertido en un
foco de los esfuerzos del líder
izquierdista Pues para priorizar el
cambio climático y la protección del
medio ambiente en su agenda
internacional Brasil también está en
conversaciones con Francia y Japón y la
Unión Europea sobre nuevas
contribuciones al fondo y bien y Cuál es
nuestra cifra del día Juan Pablo la
cifra del día son los Diez mil millones
de dólares que el gobierno de Centro
izquierda de Australia prometió incluir
en el presupuesto Federal para aliviar
el costo de vida que el primer en el
primer trimestre de este año llegó a una
inflación anual del 7%, la más alta en
por lo menos dos décadas allá pues este
tema inflación se evalúa trimestralmente
y el y en el trimestre anterior alcanzó
el
7,3%, Esa es la más alta incluso 30 años
entonces ya están evaluando esos temas y
también pues van a subir los salarios
vamos a ver cómo nivelan todo esto para
que no aumente la inflación Claro que sí
Juan Pablo lucumí con la información
económica gracias Nos vemos Esta semana
Entonces con más información económica
en directo Así es mañana con mucho más
de economía muy bien a descansar